there's dwight smith jr as we begin the
second
oh that bat will not be used again
the umpire got hit and i hope he's okay
pat holberg is holding his left arm
sliced him up
he bleed pretty good had about 17
different pieces of shrapnel coming off
of this bat
oh it did get jt and then it got the
umpire that is scary holberg wants to
continue bruce leads it off
over to first under the glove of davis
and that will head to the corner and
bruce will head to second base
thank you
the runners on the corners
for mccutcheon
runner goes pitch is shot the other way
of base hit heading toward right center
field one run is that hazley is motored
around third the throw goes to second
he'll score that's a two-run single
from mccutcheon and the phillies take a
two-nothing lead home half of the fifth
inning and here's jay bruce jay reached
out an error his first time up by chris
davis and then scored
oh man this ball is crushed deep to
right center field into the second deck
yeah it needed some help didn't it jay
bruce's solo home run is third of the
year
it's three nothing phillies that's how
you hunt the heater there tom
shook off the first pitch splitter
now i'm gonna throw this split this
sinker out there on the other half we go
to the sixth it's three-nothing phillies
as zack wheeler delivers to anthony
santander there there's a shot to right
field harper goes onto the warning track
to play turns fires this one into words
second santander digging for two he's in
there
that's renato nunez nunez walked in the
first had a double to right in the third
inning
and hits this one to left field for a
base hit
[Applause]
round third he'll score an rbi for
renato nunez and the orioles around the
board and tying run it to play ruiz with
a base hit and his first at bat and then
hit a line drive
one two lined in the left
that's a fair ball down the left field
line and heads into the corner turning
second base is nunez nunez getting the
send around from flores gregorius will
not throw this one home rio ruiz with an
rbi double the left how about you rio
bring dwight smith to the plate
phil's lead the birds 3-2
hit hard off the second baseman and that
should get him in
ruiz around third heading to the plate
we've got a tie baseball game
base hit for dwight smith in an rbi
orioles have made some adjustments
they've not missed in this inning when
wheeler has made a mistake they have
made him pay for an outstanding effort
by kingery but he couldn't come up with
it and ball just squirts out towards
right field they like lead it off with a
base hit here brings up alberto
ripped fairball into the left field
corner
polka around second headed to third
ball rolls around malaika gets the green
light he's coming home here's the throw
he's in and the orioles have the lead
throw gets away and all the way to third
goes hanser alberto
the hitting machine hits again
and here's santander shorten that stroke
just find the barrel get it out of the
infield and drive home another run
that should do it base hit into center
alberto can walk home and the orioles
are up 5-3
for the sixth and the seventh inning for
the orioles has been fun to watch and
they do it again pick up a fifth run so
here is bryce harper
out toward left field going back on it
is velasquez to the wall it is gone
it carried out of the yard on opposite
field home run for price he's just tied
this baby up at five
and the fandemic crew is loving it
putting it back are you kidding me
no stride good follow through two down
now it'll bring up gene
in the air to left field the phillies
have just taken the
lead gene sigoura goes yard his second
home run of the year
it's a 6'5 ball game
i'm sara alberto
to right field and it's in the gap
davis
legs around second he'll get into third
and the orioles have runners on second
and third with one out
tying run on second renato nunez
left field base hit that'll tie the game
and the runners will hold and the bases
remain loaded renato nunez with an rbi
base hit davis scores and we are tied
left up to pedro severino now
popped him up
on the infield
whoa
oh no it falls in
the orioles have scored two more runs
miscommunication i heard her late i got
it i got it wow it falls near the mound
and the orioles have an eight to six
lead back-to-back walks the bases are
loaded the tying run is at second the
winning run is at first indeed is up
swinging a floater out towards center
field that one is going to drop in for a
base hit one run is in here comes harper
nobody's covering third the phillies
have tied it up they're the bottom of
the ninth inning it's an eight eight
game
he does have one base hit tonight but he
got a chance to
laced into center field that's a base
hit look out hayes might go all the way
around on this one quinn finally chases
it down
he's got the green light and austin
hayes is going to score
and jay bruce
will be the hitter
that one's pulled into right field
that'll be it for a base hit sigour is
around third he's heading for home it'll
be an rbi single for jay bruce the
phillies are within one it's a 10-9 game
and lakin's trying to end it he can get
reese hoskins out hoskins with hits his
last two at bats
lakins one two bounce to short
over to first and the orioles win it
in a game that
just wouldn't end for a while the
orioles find a way
the inside the park home run part of the
big story but there were about 20
different twists and turns in this game
and how about travis lakin picks up his
first big league save in his 23rd career
game